the left is already in full resistance
mode over judge Cavanaugh left-wing
agitators and politicians began
protesting his nomination in front of
the Supreme Court they must have had a
lot of different signs that he'll know
Kony Barrett he'll know Hardiman but
they had to put up the Cavanaugh sign
well a left-wing Center for American
Progress put together tonight's protest
joining me now for reaction Chris Hahn
former advisor to Senate Majority
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer harmie
Dylan the RNC committee woman in
California and Matthew Lemke an attorney
in Alabama who previously clerked for
Justice Kennedy it's been following this
very closely it's great to have all of
you on tonight Matt let's start with you
Justice Kennedy for whom you clerked I'm
wondering what he's thinking tonight
he's probably he's probably over the
moon but that association with both
Justice Kennedy and the bushes did give
a lot of conservatives before we get
into the resistance pause about judge
Kavanagh whether he'd be the right type
of justice whether he'd evolved in the
role Matt you know Brett and you know
Justice Kennedy what are your thoughts
night after watching this this all
unfold well I think it's a great night
for Justice Kennedy he's got to be
immensely proud that his law clerk has
been nominated to the court it will be
his second law clerk on the court if
judge Kavanagh has confirmed because of
course judge corsets now justice
gorgeous Gorsuch also clerked for
Justice Kennedy but I think in terms of
the conservative concerns look there's a
12-year record of 300 decisions by Judge
Cavanaugh that show that he is a
principled conservative who believes in
judicial restraint
and believes that he's not the hundred
and first senator some super legislator
but instead he's there to interpret the
law President Trump had four great
candidates I think any one of them would
have made a terrific nominee and people
had their favourites but now I think
people will rally around all
conservatives will rally around judge
Cavanaugh because he really is a
principled conservative that we can
count on well except the protesters and
Chris I mean that's your party there
tonight at the court I mean they're kind
of straggling around now but they had
all their pre-printed signs up you you
you have the nay rail people you had the
Planned Parenthood people yet Center for
American Progress I didn't find that
display tonight I mean as I'm trying to
put myself as an outside observer which
is hard given my background clerking on
the court and so forth none of that
seemed attractive to me it also it
seemed in poor form and it seemed like
it doesn't matter who the president
nominee he could have nominated Merrick
garland they probably have a garland
resist garland sign up there your
reaction to what I'm doing at your court
if if he were to nominated garland I'd
be here talking about how great a
president Donald Trump was development
but but I will say this look Merrick
garland it all comes back to it that is
what set this up right so the left wing
of the Democratic Party the Democratic
Party as a whole has no choice but to
resist this nominee regardless of his
qualifications regardless of his
background because they feel like their
nominee was stolen by Mitch McConnell
two years ago and as a result we are we
are in for probably the Superbowl of all
super bowls of battles in Congress over
the next couple of weeks and I think
October 1 is a very aggressive deadline
especially given the fact that he has
300 decisions that people are gonna have
to wade through and understand and he's
getting a lot of questions on those and
remember I heard mr. Leo talked about
the Federalist Papers my favorite
Federalist paper is Bill is 51 ambition
must counteract ambition and Congress
has lacked ambition to counteract this
president and check it so the courts
probably the last resort here so
Democrats have to take that into account
when they when they look into this
background Harmy Bernie Sanders was out
there
in full resistance mode after Judge
Cavanaugh's announcement tonight by the
president but Bernie was it's all hot
and bothered let's watch what we are
talking about here is in a moment in
American history where we have
right-wing extremists controlling the
House the Senate and the White House if
we appoint another right-wing extremist
to the Supreme Court I have very serious
concerns about justice in this country
and what will happen to the men women
and children and the future of our
nation are made I think the left is
gonna try to use this to whip up you
know votes in the fall on the midterm
election cycle that's why they want to
put this off if they can until after the
midterms I think they're not gonna be
able to do that but your reaction Bernie
Sanders is still very popular fill
stadiums unlike other people who want
wanted to be president your reaction to
his time as tonight before the court
announcement well I think it's ironic
that this whole thing has occurred
because because Hillary Clinton rigged
the whole democratic process so that
Bernie Sanders couldn't get traction in
it and now here we are I mean you know
as a conservative and I'm very grateful
that that Donald Trump is not making the
second terrific pick but the reality
laura is no matter who had been picked
and remember in the corset situation
Democrats had these blank signs and they
actually took markers there and they
filled in the blanks as to who was the
person they're gonna be protesting as
I'm sure that was happening today as
well in DC it doesn't matter who it is
it doesn't matter who it was it could've
been anyone on that list of 25 or even
any conservative and the same hysterical
reaction would have been there I mean
it's an hour later not even an hour
later and blood is already running in
the streets according to these people
but remember that the same crowd mayor
al now remember people for the American
Way
they said that justice Souter was going
to overturn roe v wade we have been
hearing this it's that's not down to
Merrick garland Leoben hearings Osteria
overreaction dating back to Bork and
before each time they got it wrong and
and if the boy who cried wolf nobody's
taking me seriously
hold on hold on Chris Matt I we got
about 15 seconds Matt if there's one
thing that Brett Kavanaugh could do to
sway a Collins and a Murkowski I mean do
you think they're going to be a problem
in this ultimately well I think he's
going to emphasize the importance of
story decisis the idea that Court should
be very hesitant to overturn precedent
and I'm just going to think about it
that's right an independent to be sure
we're out of time